foreign
now for one more thing and Greg you go
first all right first of all we got a
great show tonight we have on my show
somebody by the name of Dana Perino
Jamie listow Guy Benson cat tip All
Stars take that bread bear let's do this
Greg's watch this carefully now I got a
buddy his name's Vic he's a juggly likes
a Juggle uh hula hoops and I said you
know maybe you should get a real job but
he still does this now Watch What
Happens he's usually pretty good and he
likes to juggle his hula hoops you know
and I always say watch this carefully
because uh something happened there yeah
oh yeah see that nice he's juggling his
hula hoop seagull and the seagull came
and took his hula hoop I believe you but
I still can't see it yeah
I've started out a GoFundMe page to help
replace this hula hoop we're up to 17
million dollars wow yeah yeah wow
I love this story are you ready for my
one more thing so it caught my attention
it's a new group of Americans and they
are in Upstate New York in Rochester
they are refugees who have previously
voted for Democrats but now feel their
voice is not heard they are part of the
Rochester Refugee political advocacy and
engagement group and on behalf of the
refugee Community they are endorsing
political candidate Laurent Singletary
for congress they say safety is a really
important issue to them and Lauren
Singletary created a liaison with this
group violence in Rochester is really
high judge you know that it's a really
bad problem he's a former police chief
and so these are 60 Community leaders
from Bhutan uh they're Burmese Somali
Indian Trinidad Vietnamese Afghan
community so in my opinion
this shows democracy is not dying
tomorrow that's pretty cool Jesse
refugees for Republicans that's what
I've been saying for years how many
times have I said that you were way
ahead of the key all right so download
the free and I emphasize free Fox bet
Super 6 app and play the midterm
election contest for a chance to win 25
000 you can buy a lot of hula hoops for
that that is true but six outcomes you
pick them for the contest and then watch
the results on Fox news on November 8th
you download it and you play it for free
tonight Jesse Waters prime time I do my
midterm predictions and if I'm wrong
just delete the DVR no it's like it
never happened
okay just like the marathon
Jessica
that was really crappy of you guys
as many of you know the New York City
marathon took place yesterday but you
probably didn't know was that the Hulk
was in attendance to help cheer on the
runners see we're mean about a little
kid oh I know I wasn't well but now
Jessica yep yes you were don't hide
behind a child I also wanted to give a
shout out to Evans tribet who won in the
men's division and Sharon lucetti who
won in the women's division both of whom
are from Kenya incredible performances
just a fun day every year they win every
year yeah
yeah every year you're right they're
great all right it's my turn yes now
sometimes Justice surfs itself take a
look at this video from Washington State
this Brazen Thief thought he was getting
away with over eighteen thousand dollars
worth of handbags from Louis Vuitton
instead he ran directly into a breakfast
window locked himself out while trying
to make off with the goods yes the 17
year old suspect is part of a retail
crime
known in Washington he thought he was
getting away with it the police didn't
even have to rush to get him he was
unconscious Now That's What I Call Law
and Order right Greg I can watch that
every day we need more glass doors to
fight crime that's true clean doors